Oh doctor crack butt neck crack Manette
I think it's Doug hey how's it going
guys so I went back to a Sacramento this
week it was kind of make sure I don't
get to stay that long but there was a
couple of things that I had to do
obviously if I'm only be there for a
couple of days the first thing I have to
do is share a meal with my parents and
we went to there's one spot I think it's
called it's called poke young in
Sacramento California or Peking panda
panda but I've been going to this
restaurant since I was a kid and they
serve Chinese influenced Korean food
which is like stuff like John and John
Paul if you guys haven't had that I
don't I don't know what's called in
English just like now every time I go to
Sacramento I have to for sure see my
best friend Gobbo now if you guys have
been a part of David's or company since
the beginning you guys do remember who
gobble is because he was a part of all
my videos in the beginning
so before I even get the Sacramento
gobble calls me up because look I got
this bro date going on we've got the
GoPro man sitting with me you and
Williams but I'm not gonna tell you
where we're going or what it is you know
you can't just take people places
without telling them no it's college
it's shocking what the purpose is for
you withholding this information I don't
like surprises
now the thing about Gobbo is whenever he
plans something out that should never go
through so for me I always ask him like
where we're gonna go what time is it so
I could check out the weather just to
see if something's gonna go down but he
never wants to tell me every time I ask
the [ __ ] tells me to shut up and so
where does he decide to take me in
William he picks us on a bromance date
to a National Forest where they have
huge sequoias and of cord before I got
that he gave me some vague information
he told me that all I had to bring was a
pair of shorts some shoes and a shirt
well [ __ ] what happened do y'all see
this [ __ ] it's [ __ ] raining like a
monster out here
Gobbo you suck at planning look at this
[ __ ] she's walking away with a damn dog
you know what dude yeah yeah I got [ __ ]
but a t-shirt of shorts don't you tell
me to come it's raining outside you are
the worst planner on earth did you plan
for this I hate this fool so much and he
just refuses to admit fault
I'm gonna choke this fool doubt it was
[ __ ] ridiculous it was like 50
degrees out
I had no clothes on the only thing that
was protecting me from the rain was his
plastic bag which by the way I look like
a [ __ ] condom look at the weather man
you did not work no you did not assess
the situation at all how do you feel
about the situation that we're in will
you know what I kind of expected it from
agava I don't think there's ever been a
plan that you planned out that ever
worked out the way you wanted it to most
plans don't work out well right I know
both plans do and now we look like a
bunch of giant condoms a big-ass condom
it wouldn't be a trip of Gobbo if things
didn't [ __ ] up
that's not the saying goes do you see
this right now the situation that we're
in what's the weather like right now
sprinkly want you I want you to say that
while looking at your trojan friend over
here but despite all the negative things
that I've said about Gobbo that dumbass
and the trip I can't remember what this
park was called but this National Forest
was absolutely amazing I think the
reason why goblin wanted to take me a
William that was because you know like
you get caught up in your work so much
it's just good to kind of get away from
technology in the city it really helps
you to like reset your batteries you
know I'm saying you know the error was
super fresh out there even if it was
raining but the amazing thing about the
Sequoia for so these are ancient trees
and when you stand next to them you kind
of realize how small you are not penis
wise but you know your body in relation
to the trees my penis is fine it's a
solid 12 inch no savages look we
survived big trees National Park it was
coming down my dog is soaked look like
he gelled his hair film Simba nice and
it had a good high cuz a good day
getting out kind of early which is good
we have a 10-year high school reunion so
we're gonna get dressed though so we get
ratchet later I don't know what I'm
doing back out they were so comedy I
promised myself I'd never do this [ __ ]
again but I lost the bet so
welcome to another episode of fat free
ducks tour guide here we have the forest
and it is raining it reminds me of with
them all the time in Vietnam it's red
summertime springtime wedding birthday
with my baby born when I have the bad
date a good day
excuse me Nabal who is the Far East